avec cette arrivée massive de demandeurs
d'asile à la frontière cet effet on
s'est demandé si ça leur prenait
beaucoup plus de temps pour obtenir un
permis travail christian bégin et nous
envoyer un courriel
est ce que les haïtiens qui n'ont pas de
statut légal au canada ont le droit de
travailler
bon d'abord les personnes qu'on a vu
entrer au pays et qui ne passait pas par
les postes frontières parce qu'elles ont
fait une demande d'asile
elles ont le droit d'être sur le
territoire ce ne sont pas des illégaux
pour pouvoir travailler par contre il
faut un permis de travail
obtenir un permis travail en 2014
prenait pour les demandeurs d'asile
soixante quatre jours dans la première
moitié de 2010 est ça prenait presque le
double cent douze jours
112 jours ça c'était en juin alors que
la vague de demandeurs d'asile à la
frontière continuer d'augmenter
à l'heure actuelle les délais sont de 10
à 15 semaines mais immigration canada
veut ramener le taux à 30 jours ensuite
une fois qu'on ne sont permis travail
faut faire une demande de numéros
d'assurance sociale parce que le
gouvernement est l'employeur en auront
besoin
donc en attendant de savoir s'ils
peuvent rester au pays
les demandeurs d'asile peuvent
travailler ils ont aussi le droit à des
soins de santé à des cours de français à
l'éducation et à l'aide au logement
si au bout de tout le processus la
personne se fait dire qu'elle ne peut
pas rester au canada
évidemment un père son permis travail si
comme suit bégin vous voulez qu'on
vérifie quelque chose
écrivez nous
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]